je retrouve le dr karl weiss président
de l'association des médecins des
microbiologistes infectiologues du
québec dr weiss bonsoir un petit mot sur
la courbe quand même parce que je début
de tendance là oui oui oui on est
prudent mais tout de même le nombre de
quotidiens a tendance à diminuer là je
vous montre la courbe pour les décès
l'augmentation des décès quotidiens qui
a tendance à diminuer également vous en
êtes où dans l'analyse des données dr
weiss dans l'écouté c'est encourageant
mais il faut être encore une fois très
prudent parce qu'on fait pas des
statistiques avec une de données sur une
ou deux journées
mais il est clair que si on continue sur
cette tendance là ça veut dire qu'on est
dans la partie descendante de la cour
pour cette phase de la pandémie
on prend qui aura plusieurs phases mais
au moins c'est encourageant on n'a pas
tellement on n'a pas plus
d'hospitalisations le nombre de passions
soin intensif est très stable même un
peu en diminution et là on a une
diminution de la mortalité après avoir
eu des chiffres qui ont été absolument
horrible là au moins on a des
diminutions qui est encourageante et je
pense qu'il faut commencer à regarder ça
de façon assez aux plus optimistes on va
dire surtout avec du déconfinement mais
d'un autre côté il faut quand même pas
oublier que quand on ya cinquante
personnes au québec qui perd une journée
c'est 50 10 parties ces cinquante
familles qui sont affligés et ses
cinquante personnes qui ont contribué à
l'histoire du québec ne sont plus avec
nous bien sûr
l'hydrochlorothiazide en europe annoncé
qu'il en prenait un petit comprimé allez
hop tous les jours pour se prémunir pour
ne pas attraper je vous fait entendre un
petit extrait du président peut on vient
tout de suite c'est très con alors il
dit ça peut pas nous faire du mal en
prévention pourquoi pas qu'en pensez
vous
écoutez n'y a pas de données
actuellement pour dire telle hydroxy
chloroquine en prévention est utile donc
moi ce que je recommanderai aux gens
c'est de ne pas en prendre en prévention
c'est un médicament qui est quand même
relativement bien tolérée qui a pas
d'effets secondaires énorme mais qui
chez des gens qui prennent d'autres
médicaments peut quand même donner des
effets secondaires vous savez il ya des
gens qui prennent des drogues cip le
rocking par exemple les gens qui font du
bus
les gens qui font battre une prime
atomique dans certains cas donc il ya
ces gens à l'interné des problèmes
rhumatologie qui prennent hydroxyque le
rocking depuis longtemps d'ailleurs il
ya une étude aux états unis qui
regardent ces gens là est-ce qu'ils vont
avoir moins de covin et s'ils vont faire
la couv idée ce qu'elle va être moins
sévère donc une cohorte actuellement qui
est en train d'être suivies aux états
unis par rapport à simple mais en
prophylaxie à l'étape actuelle
aujourd'hui il ya aucune donnée qui
porte le fait d'en prendre et moi je
déconseillerais très fortement à qui que
ce soit d'aller appeler son médecin ou
pire encore d'aller sur l'internet il eu
dans la qualité n'est pas connue diderot
xi chloroquine et de commencer à les
consommer ce serait probablement une
erreur
donc né pour prévenir dit vous ni pour
guérir ben guérir on sait pas guérir je
vous dirais les données sont très
mitigés s'il ya une activité dans la
guérison
c'est pour des excréments par les deux
choses différentes le président trump
n'est pas malade il se dit moi je
prendre ses médicaments là pour ne pas
tomber malade c'est autre chose ça
s'appelle la prophylaxie blaya aucune
donnée pour les gens qui sont malades
commence à avoir des symptômes kit est
positive pour la covin bain pour ces
gens là s'il ya une utilité c'est
peut-être j'ai des gens qui sont très
peu malade trait au début de la maladie
prise en compte de façon concomitante
avec un autre médicament qui hélas trop
ici donc c'est beaucoup de plus en même
temps et c'est peut-être là où il ya un
effet possible mais là encore il n'y a
absolument rien de prouvé et je vous
dirais que le jury actuellement alors il
ya on vit semaine était plutôt neutre
est plutôt dans la tendance voilà c'est
ce que les deux dernières études le
montrait que j'ai pu lire en fin de
semaine dernière que savait pas d'effet
mais quand vous êtes s'est pas terminée
mais ça s'en va plutôt vers
le non pas des faits par les web de la
course au vaccin au lit presque à tous
les jours maintenant
bon certains sont déjà rendus à la
deuxième phase est ce que vous trouvez
ça prometteur est ce que ça qu'est ce
que ça vous dit sur l'échelle du thym
conquis devant nous avant d'avoir un
vaccin
bon alors la première chose qu'il faut
savoir qu'il ya au plus d'une centaine
de vaccins qui sont actuellement
développe le deuxièmement il ya une
compétition au niveau des étages qui va
arriver à voir il ya aussi une
compétition au niveau de petites
compagnies qui veulent se positionner
pour toutes sortes de raisons à avoir
des fonds avoir des fonds de recherche
est racheté par de grosses
multinationales peu importe voir leurs
actions monter en bourse pour sortir des
résultats très préliminaire peut-être
encourageant mais très préliminaire et
si on dénombre très petit donc ce que ça
nous dit actuellement c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de développement
on espère pouvoir un vaccin la réponse
va vraiment être quand on va être dans
la phase 2 et que la phase de ce plan où
commence la phase 1
c'est à dire on donne ça quelques
volontaires pour s'assurer que les gens
peut-être des anticorps et surtout qu'il
n'ait pas de conséquences très sévère de
recevoir le vaccin
parce que dans un vaccin il ya deux
qualités importantes la sécurité et
d'efficacité pour que ça marche mais il
faut pas que ça vous donne non plus des
effets secondaires désastreux
donc par rapport à ces deux choses là
c'est ce qu'on va tester initialement si
après une phase ii on s'aperçoit que les
vaccins comment ça va être un peu plus
prometteurs on pourrait voir des signes
encourageants mais là encore faut pas
aller trop vite pour aller trop vite et
donner l'impression qu'on a trouvé
quelque chose il vaut mieux avoir des
vaccins qui soit efficace
plutôt que d'avoir quelque chose de
pâques les avec une protection qui va
être réveillé il faut être optimiste
mais on aura rien avant qu'ils ont 12 -
minimum dans le meilleur des cas et le
plus optimiste des scénarii voilà ses
instincts ma question je voulais vous
faire préciser donc pour vous vous
n'avez pas changé d'avis sur sur le
temps nécessaire minimale puis douze
mois c'est vraiment c'est sa c6 à
presque un miracle
oui parce que vous savez que si vous
étiez président d'une compagnie qui
voulait développer un nouveau vaccin ça
prend environ 6 7 ans 8 ans
entre le moment où on dit on commence à
travailler sur un vaccin et on va
l'amener sur le marché donc déjà même si
on arrivait en 12 à 19 ans a fait un
vaccin ce serait quelque chose de
phénoménal
parce que c'est quand même pas évident
et c'est quelque chose où on n'a pas
d'expérience pour vous rappeler le h1n1
influença on sait faire des vaccins
contre la grippe
on n'a jamais fait de vaccins contre le
coroner donc c'est toute une nouvelle
recette qu'il va falloir trouver
est ce que c'est ce qui rend les choses
beaucoup plus compliquées
dr weiss une question du public en
terminant mon petit fils numéro 4 mon
petit fils de 6 ans souffrent d'eczéma
avec le désinfectant utilisé à l'école
et je sais qu'on se lave les mains
souvent son examen s'est aggravée et lui
fait mal existe il une alternative
écoutez l'eau et le savon c'est très bon
mais probablement qu'il aurait besoin
d'un traitement et d'aller voir donc un
dermatologue par rapport à ça mais il ya
aussi l'hydratation des mains qui est
très importante mais si vraiment en
examen ce jeudi rey se détériore en solo
en mettant des jeunes alcoolisés
une façon naturelle comme les autres
c'est que ça veut dire qu'il aurait
probablement besoin d'être vu par un
dermatologue pour lui donner le meilleur
traitement possible et le plus ajustée
merci beaucoup dr weiss à très bientôt
bonne soirée